hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2019 american science fiction
comedy an action movie called rim of the
world
the movie begins with a huge alien
spaceship that is approaching the earth
in the half wrecked international space
station space engineer major collins
attempts to send the coordinates to a
scientist at nasa jet propulsion
laboratory or jpl called dr fielding
technical problem occurs and she is told
to put the coordinates on the crypto key
manually and deliver it to the doctor
herself
not long after the iss loses its power
and collins is attacked by the alien on
earth alex a socially awkward boy who is
obsessed with space technologies is
going to attend rim of the world summer
camp in southern california his mother
is optimistic that alex will make new
friends there alex's dad died in a fire
several years ago when he tried to save
his family since then alex has been
wearing his dad's watch everywhere he
goes a chinese girl named zhen zhen is
being questioned by the immigration
officer because her guardian does not
look like her at all
he claims that she is his niece and the
officer eventually allows her to pass
shenzhen successfully tricks the officer
and pays that man to disguise as her
guardian
she is also on her way to the rim of the
world
last but not least there is darush a
rich and very talkative kid saying
goodbye to his parents before leaving
for the summer camp
long story short alex and his mom arrive
at the camp and are welcomed by team
leader logan he introduces carl to him
and shows him a black man handshake
which only black men are allowed to
perform says logan he then persuades
alex to dance to the music but it seems
he is not that kind of person a few
moments later alex approaches zhan jan
and introduces himself and mandarin to
her but she doesn't respond to him at
all
an instructor orders daryush to hand
over his cell phone to her saying put it
in my box
but he misunderstands the words which
makes her confused and offended at the
same time before the summer camp begins
alex's mom hugs and kisses his boy in
front of other participants which makes
him embarrassed
alex attempts to conquer the first post
of the camp which is flying fox turns
out that he is afraid of heights
logan tries to calm him down but it
doesn't make him better and alex decides
to pull back and go down
later that night alex chooses to play
rubik and stay away from the others he
walks towards the bridge and meets
shenzhen there but none of them tries to
start the conversation
the next day the kids are brought to the
lake to do canoeing but the canoe is not
available because some kids [ __ ] on
it not interested shenzhen wanders off
into the woods while alex secretly
follows her from behind she finally
reaches the lookout point pictured in
the summer camp poster and feels
relieved daryus suddenly shows up from
the tree after dropping a deuce and
attempts to help alex to conquer his
fear of height alex is scared to death
but suddenly a cool kid named gabriel
shows up out of nowhere and intervenes
offended the cocky daryush unleashes his
inner jet li and attempts to attack him
but he punches him in the face knocking
him down in one punch and helping alex
suddenly an explosion sound occurs and
they receive warning messages telling
them to evacuate immediately and warning
them not to approach any alien aircraft
they run back to the lake but everyone's
gone
second explosion in the atmosphere
occurs and this time an emp is shut down
all their phones while unknown planes
suddenly pass across the lake
gabriel states that they will not
survive the wilderness and the kids
decide to head back to the camp only to
discover that they have been left behind
the drunk conrad is also left behind
alex explains that the nuclear explosion
in the atmosphere earlier might cause
the emp which kills all the electronic
devices within the radius
not long after an aerial battle between
human and alien occurs while the kids
attempt to run away
suddenly a human spacecraft from the iss
called dragon lands heavily in front of
them
a dying space engineer shows up and
hands over a key that contains
coordinates to alex telling them to give
the key to doctor fielding at jpl
facility which is located 70 miles away
from there
suddenly a wild alien appears and kills
the woman
it summons a smaller alien creature to
chase after the kids
they run to a building and attempt to
hide there the small alien spot star you
shin chases after him but he can outrun
it they are eventually cornered and had
runs towards them luckily shenzhen
manages to trap the creature
not long after the big alien emerges and
attempts to attack alex alex and the
girl hide inside a toilet full of feces
while daryush and gabriel hide below the
ladder conrad is instantly killed by the
alien while he is peeing
seeing the smaller alien is escaping
from the building gabriel and daryush
run toward the spacecraft and lock
themselves there outside the ship alex
and zhen zhen try to dodge the alien
while gabriel accidentally presses the
ignition button frying the small alien
into dust
suddenly the mother alien shows up and
attacks the kids
luckily several jet planes appear and
shoot the alien temporarily killing it
after that for the first time the
chinese girl finally speaks up
suggesting they move forward and hand
over the key which surprised the boys
they then steal the bikes and start
their journey to the nasa facility at
pasadena before they go alex admits that
he cannot ride a bike but after his
friends help him he eventually manages
to ride it a minute later he falls off
the bike they are shocked when they see
that the entire city has been destroyed
on the other side it is revealed that
the alien is still alive as the bullets
just fall out of its body
upon reaching the city they stop by a
police station and discover a criminal
lu who has been left behind in the cell
at first daryush refuses to bring him
out but the empathetic alex and zhang
decide to release him because he claims
that he has a son waiting for him the
kids continue their journey and are
confronted by soldiers who are
evacuating the city alex hands over the
key to the commander hoping that he will
take it to jpl he then puts the kids on
a school bus to bring them to safety
however the alien spacecraft suddenly
attack them destroying the whole convoy
the dying commander returns the key to
alex while zhen zhen takes the radio
away
all the soldiers are killed and the kids
have to continue their journey on their
own again gabriel reveals that he was in
the camp because he escaped from juvi
because his house is nearby the kids
decide to stay there for a night there
gabriel continues his story he is bad at
remembering numbers and was placed in
jail due to a misunderstanding between
him and a store owner causing his mom to
get fired and he got sent away
after that they decide to take a selfie
later that night the kids wake up after
hearing a loud banging and subsequently
attacked by masked men
turns out that the gang is led by lou
who is a bad guy and forces alex to hand
over the key which he will sell at a
high price
he refuses and suddenly the mother alien
appears and attacks the bad men killing
them
gabriel attempts to lure the alien into
a swimming pool and successfully trap it
there the next day alex realizes that it
was the same alien from the camp
explaining that it has the ability to
regenerate rapidly varus refuses to
follow alex's idea again after he let
lou escape from the cell
annoyed with daryushu keeps complaining
gabriel and daryush get into a short
fight where the rich kid reveals that
his dad is on the verge of bankruptcy
and that's why he was sent to the summer
camp
after that both of them apologized to
each other
suddenly the transmitter receives a
morse code from dr fielding indicating
that they must hurry up
they stop by a mall and change their
clothes
shenzhen reveals that she left home
because she is an unwanted kid and she
is now glad because she has a family
which is them
the kids then decide to ride an
abandoned ford mustang in the parking
lot with zhen zhen on the wheel
while they are on their way they are
attacked by the pursuing alien after
several attempts the kids decide to jump
off the vehicle while the car falls down
and traps the alien alex realizes that
he left the key in the car this time the
annoying darius finally offers himself
to go to the car and retrieve the key he
manages to reach the key but gets
scratched by the alien in the process
they eventually arrive at the jpl
facility which is half destroyed they
explored the facility only to find out
that dr fielding has been killed and the
morse code was sent by the blood
dripping onto the transmitter
suddenly they are contacted by general
george who is at first pessimistic
because dr fielding was killed
but alex manages to convince him with
his heart-touching speech
george states that the key contains
coordinates of the alien's mothership
and excalibur is the only weapon to
destroy it alex gives his watch to zheng
zhen who decides to go to the basement
to turn on the emergency generators
while he goes upstairs to realign the
communication dish
the girl successfully gets the power
back on and gabriel plugs the key to the
computer
outside alex overcomes his fear of
height and fixes the communication dish
while being chased by the alien he
manages to escape from the alien and
goes back to the building on the other
side gabriel needs to insert a password
to the vault to get the launch keys but
unfortunately he is bad at numbers
luckily the dying darush manages to
write the password on the paper and
passes out after that the chinese girl
shows up and both of them successfully
activate the excalibur which immediately
shoots laser beams toward the alien
mother ship alex lures the alien into
the engine test room where he burns the
alien to death with the engine all of
them managed to escape from the jpl
building while watching the alien
mothership is destroyed in the
atmosphere
celebrating their success to save
humanity alex and jen gen kiss
at the end of the movie alex is reunited
with his mom and they are considered
heroes by the people
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching